The goals of Valient load balancing in the VL Two network are to spread
traffic evenly across the servers, and to ensure that traffic load
is balanced independently of the destinations of the traffic flows.
Field two achieves this by inserting an indirection level. Into the switching
hierarchy. When a switch at the access
layer wants to send traffic to a destination, it first selects a switch
at the indirection level to send the traffic at random. This intermediate switch
then forwards the traffic to the
ultimate destination Depending on the destination MAC
address, of the traffic. Subsequent flows might
pick different, indirection, points for the traffic,
at random. This notion of picking a random indirection point, to balance traffic
more evenly, across a topology, actually comes
from multi-processor architectures. And has been rediscovered
in the context of data centers. So, in this lesson we have explored how valiant
load balancing can be used on a slightly modified topology. To achieve
better load balance than in traditional fat tree networks,
without an interaction layer, and valiant load balancing. In the
next lesson we'll look at how a custom random topology
can make some of these traffic engineering problems even easier.